i mean my my boy bruce willis he's going
through a lot of yeah different times
right now and i feel for him and big
hugs to him and his family and
i miss him i really do anyway but back
in the day when bruce was
and he still is
he's a [ __ ] massive movie star and
bruce my first hollywood movie was the
last boy scout so
you know
you talk about auditioning right so i'm
i'm you know i just finished broadway
street car and
things have taken off and all these uh
casting people marion dougherty the late
marion dougherty
she said you're gonna be a [ __ ] star
kid and here we go and she got me this
audition for the last boy scout
there's like three scenes and i remember
going on tape for her in new york and
that's back in the day this is early 90s
91 maybe and they flew you out they flew
you out for an audition they put you up
i i had a real audition with tony scott
the late great tony scott
he's gone now too and phil silver and
we're sitting in this room a really
small [ __ ] room and i'm doing this
audition and
i walk out of the room and the casting
chick comes out it wasn't mary and it
was the la equivalent marion stayed in
new york and she said hang on hang on
and so i'm in the hallway
and tony comes busting and goes yeah
yeah you got it we got it i went i got
it
and i said you're offering me a [ __ ]
chat he goes oh yeah yeah yeah it's in a
couple weeks so i go back got the part
now you got to hear this
so true story i uh i go to set
and it's back in la and i don't know if
you remember the last boy scout but it
was a football team dude i loved it i
remember you just stole the [ __ ] out of
that one scene too yeah yeah yeah yeah
so we did that scene later my first
scene
was at a we're getting a newspaper and
damon wayans comes to get a newspaper
and me and my two thugs we walk up when
i say someone he doesn't look too tough
to me he doesn't look too tough so the
scene was end up punching him right in
the face right
and so
i get to say
and i'm in my wardrobe and my shoes that
they've given me are super slippery like
they're [ __ ] slippery as [ __ ] and i'm
sliding all over and i i was a little
and i'm in a little honey wagon i don't
even have my own bathroom i'm like
completely green right i got nothing so
but i've got this big movie so i go can
we and they go no just get some
coca-cola pour some cocoa in the bottom
you'll be fine you'll be fine okay so i
get the set i meet the stunt guy we go
over the punch
it's going well
it's time for the punch
and the punch goes pretty good
and tony comes up everyone's there
willis isn't there yet i haven't met him
yet but everyone's there and tony comes
up and goes okay right mate we got that
we got that we got that now now this is
one more one more go just go for it we
got it's all done we go but go you go i
go
all right
so we do one more action
he comes up we do the thing
and i punched him right in the face
my back foot slipped michael and my my
fist went farther than it should have
and it hit him right right underneath
the glasses he had sunglasses on
the glasses come off his face he's
holding his face
i'm like so shocked at what i had done
the stunt guy comes up because it wasn't
your [ __ ] fault man i saw your foot
slip said [ __ ] shoes fault wasn't
your fault wasn't you i i'm just going
i'm so sorry silver comes running up
tony comes running up and damon wayans
gets up off the ground and goes i'm okay
i'm okay i'm all right let's go let's do
it again i'm i'm all right tony goes no
we got that we're moving on i thought i
was going to get fired on my very first
day of my first big you punched damon
wayans in the face
yeah on your first day of work on the
huge blockbuster movie